[Music]
we have a great show tonight but before
we continue I thought we'd take a minute
to check in with Andy rector see what
stupid stories that idiots working on
for next week I hate and I think America
does too judging by the emails Andy gone
and we're off next week so I'm not gonna
be a party to your lies anymore
no thanks Conan
and finally potato chips pretzels honey
roasted peanuts can listing types of
snacks make this segment longer thanks
Andy you're a bad guy and you'll listen
to everything I have to say everything
oh wait
I'm going into your brain let's see him
stay there and then try going to your
brain oh oh I'm sorry I wasn't looking
I'm just trying to see if they can wait
oh wait oh wait wait and make a week
yeah make a wink of wink a sound look
there you go save that make yourself a
candle you say and finally can come you
could say and finally can Conan do a
cheap illusion to make it look like he's
cleaning my ear and finally can Conan do
it cheaper gonna tiny Conan clean my
ears you Betty can oh yeah if you took a
little that way little further get in
there
[Music]